hey everybody
movie retrospective time guess what one
we're doing today this one won
the patreon poll by a landslide
i think the other movies in the poll
only got one vote
everybody wanted this one everybody
wanted this one this one is young
frankenstein a [ __ ] classic yeah it's
a masterpiece
from 1974. yeah yeah back when everybody
was pretty
yeah trey guard pretty [ __ ] everybody
was pretty in the movie
[ __ ] wasn't it madeleine khan
khan was in there she was
she dressed up as an old chick she was
an old
cloris leitchman i mean i think she was
older than the others but she wasn't
i don't think she was as old as uh as
she portrayed even gene
wilder's pretty in this yeah he was a
good looking guy
you know he was actually yeah he had his
hair all done he did a couple
tap dance numbers and stuff and his
tuxedo entails along with
bugging frankenstein he just uh he it's
just
he he was just kind of a class act that
guy he really made this movie
well the thing about it what's
interesting about this obviously this is
a mel brooks movie this actually came
out the same year as blazing saddles
which i forgot i was like so that's two
[ __ ] brilliant movies yeah
coming out the same year i haven't seen
either one of these in [ __ ] forever
this one i hadn't seen it's in decades
i i was worried about how it would age
now it aged pretty well it's kind of
like ed wood
yeah i mean the thing okay so the thing
about this one i mean i know mel
brooks did a lot of sort of i guess you
call them like parody sort of films
right i mean blazing saddles was like a
parody of the western genre
you know he did uh spaceballs which was
like a sci-fi
thing you know he did robin hood men in
tights and i feel like
there's kind of a thing i think nowadays
they do make some
decent sort of parody films nowadays but
i think that a lot of parodies sort of
fall into
that thing where it's just like a bunch
of gags and like a bunch of jokes and it
doesn't really work
as an actual movie yeah and they tend
not to age well
yeah i mean i'm looking at stuff like
you know the scary movie franchise which
was kind of like you know they
they were ripping off scream but then
they also did gags from like whatever
horror movies were popular
and that's just like they sort of have a
plot but
it's mostly just a bunch of gags like
hey we're just recreating this
scene from you know whatever horror
movie except with
tits or something like that and it's
just it doesn't really hang together
that well i mean you had other parodies
like shawn of the dead and stuff like
that that were actually brilliant movies
in their own right
but i really do think that young
frankenstein i don't know i'd be
hard-pressed to say if
i think blazing saddles is slightly
funnier but young frankenstein is the
better movie all around and i'm always
gonna prefer young frankenstein because
i really really like
horror movies and i really really like
the universal movies and this
and young frankenstein is a parody of
the first three frankenstein movies
you got uh you know pookie just threw
the door open well hi pookie yeah what's
up
pookie wanted to be in the young
frankenstein review yeah but yeah so
it's not just a parody of like the first
frankenstein movie it also has bits from
bride of frankenstein it's bride of
frankenstein and
some stuff from son of frankenstein like
that whole bit
with the uh with the police inspector
with the wooden arm
yeah and like the darts and everything
great character there that [ __ ] he
was awesome
that character was in son of
frankenstein the original one like from
the
the original uh what and it's
exaggerated
yeah but not by as much as you might
think he he was on par
with um yeah that character reminded me
of a lot of doctor strange love
he was that good yeah peter sellers in
the [ __ ] doctor strangely yeah yeah
and you know he also kind of had a
prosthetic arm
but it was like an over-the-top germanic
sounding character
i don't know if it was you said it was
inspired based upon a original
character not a frankenstein not a
frankenstein but that guy
seeing him kind of just brought back
memories he's an iconic character in
this movie
and uh one of the good things about this
movie is that you could watch this as a
straight horror movie
it plays the horror aspect in some ways
kind of straight in terms of tone it
felt like i was watching the old
frankenstein
but then they're just funny shit's
happening during it it's
it's weird you just had to see it for
yourself yeah i was reading something i
think it was on the av club or something
like that and they were saying this is
one of the very few
parody movies that's still really funny
but you can cut the
the comic bits out and it still plays as
like a straight exactly
horror film a classic old horror film
and it's almost kind of like
um i think the guy james from
cinemassacre i think he basically said
this
plays out because a lot of the original
universal movies like bride of
frankenstein stuff had
humor in them so it's like it's almost
kind of like this could have been made
back then
it does it if you were to take the humor
mostly out
and watched it it still would have
unfolded
like a good universal horror flick from
back in the days it had been very
watchable oh yeah without the humor
but they took something that was good
and they made it even better
with it a lot of the humor in this is
because of the strength of the cast
oh yeah they got a great cast who really
knows how to deliver this material and
wilder is [ __ ]
you can tell that he's having a ball
with this so terry garr you know
everybody everybody was gave this like a
hundred percent
including the guy who played
frankenstein what was his name peter
boyle yeah he did a great job too i mean
they're they're this is a this
movie is packed with talent and soul the
movie has [ __ ] soul
and it aged very well which i can't say
that for everything mel brooks
like i used to love history of the world
when i was a kid used to watch it all
the time on hbo when it played
i saw it recently and the humor didn't
age very well
but i think blazing saddles probably
would have aged lazing saddles is still
funny and i want to see stir crazy again
i remember liking it and i think that
that might have aged well i'd like to
see stir crazy
yeah some things like from back then
have aged really well and young
frankenstein i think really did because
it wasn't of its time
it was parodying something was stir
crazy mel brooks no it wasn't no i don't
think so okay
it's just that just had gene wilder in
it yeah yeah yeah yeah but i want to see
that one again just because i remember
really liking it had richard pryor and
and and gene wilder a lot of this a lot
of the appeal of young frankenstein
is wilder without him this movie would
not have been the same it wouldn't have
been as good
i mean the awesome thing about this too
one i've heard that the set of this
movie like when they were working on it
they were all having a [ __ ] blast
like um you know and because they were
all friends a lot of them had worked
together
you can feel the energy yeah and a lot
of the stuff like a lot of the really
funny [ __ ] that's in it
uh it was is actually ad-libbed and then
it was just like so funny so they kept
it yeah um because like i said these
were all
you know professional comedic actors and
a lot of them had worked
with each other before so they were very
used to kind of just like playing into
yeah and brooks was brooks was evidently
a great director especially when he was
bumping coke when he was on
boat that's when he was his best you
know
spaceballs wasn't that good but even
when that came out i was like
and it didn't age well but this one
right here this one this one goes down
in history i think i think it's
at least in the top three mel brooks
movies high anxiety i remember being
pretty good too
yeah a lot of people said like oh and
the producers you know tell the
producers is really good
like uh gene wilder was also in that one
and i've never seen spring time for
hitler
well that's the producer producers okay
that was well that was gonna see that
one
it was the producers was about them
making a musical called spring time for
him okay i thought that was that's what
that would be no no no no no okay
you're right yeah i got to see that one
well the thing about this movie
gene wilder um actually came up with the
idea for this
he says because like i said him and mel
brooks had worked on the producers prior
and jean wilder also was a co-writer on
that too
and he came to mel brooks and he said i
want to do a frankenstein parody just
like the universal movies and mel brooks
was kind of like
i don't know they've made so many of
them i don't know if i like that idea
but then gene wilder was like yeah but i
want it to be like
a relative of the of the famous dr
frankenstein but he doesn't want to do
it
and mel brooks is like okay that's funny
so let's so let's write that
so mel so uh gene wilder essentially
like wrote this
they just came up with the script like
they just sat together and
and came up with it and a lot of the
gags that are like really
iconic so they say like the whole
putting on the ritz with uh with dr
frankenstein the monster
yeah um uh gene wilder really really
wanted that in the movie and i don't
know if mel brooks was like he was like
i think that's too silly i don't i don't
think that'll like work
but gene wilder was apparently so
adamant he's like please please please
we have to have this in the movie it's
gonna be so awesome
and then finally like mel brooks was
like okay okay we can keep it in there
yeah and that was kind of an homage to
uh king kong i think
because remember how when they captured
king kong they made him perform for the
live audience then yeah
he was chained up during that time well
later when they show um
um when they show frankenstein the
frankenstein monster he's chained up
kind of the way they had
king kong chained up so i think he was
they were kind of doing a king kong
shout
out i think during that time well mate
but there was a scene in one of the
frankenstein movies too where he had
where he had that and then there was
like the window in the back i will put
on a show
a black tie show well no yeah
remember when they unveiled king kong
down in new york that was in front of a
black tie audience yeah yeah yeah that's
that's what that's
that's what it reminded me of it's a
great movie you know and just
just this man [ __ ] gene really
[ __ ] knocked it out of the park
great cast i just liked it i mean the
thing about like i said
if if you're gonna watch young
frankenstein i mean and you should if
you haven't seen it what the [ __ ] is
even wrong with you i mean this is like
one of the best comedy movies ever made
what's funny about the [ __ ] with wilder
is that a lot of the stuff that wilder
does
if somebody else did it it wouldn't be
funny it's not so much what he's saying
it's
it's the attitude he's taken and how
he's delivering it there's certain
things that
wilder could do you know what i mean
like he would just through enunciation
he could make something funny
just by the way he said it yeah some
people are just natural comedians he's
just a
naturally funny person yeah you know
what i mean and that's kind of rare
um but the the great thing about him and
you could kind of see this when he was
in um
you know willy wonka and the chocolate
factory as well is that i
love that he could play
like really straight and really serious
yeah and that was still funny but then
but then you didn't know when he was
just gonna go like [ __ ] off the deep
end and just
like he had some like an
unpredictability he always seemed like
he was just on the edge
of of of really [ __ ] up
you're talking about like he could
explode at any moment
yeah it's like he's on the edge of his
he's on the edge of sanity
but he was funny he's funny as [ __ ] yeah
i mean
and the humor aged well because it
wasn't
it wasn't so jokes joke slash dialogue
dependent it was a lot of
physical humor and uh just the way
certain things were delivered and
they're obviously performing a story and
embellishing it
and the actors are [ __ ] with each
other and i didn't realize it was
ad-libbed but
some of it is it makes more sense now
that it was ad-libbed because sometimes
the way they would respond
especially wilder and terry garr playing
off each other
yeah and terry guard she's young as hell
on this freaking really funny and super
super cute in it
i think this might be this i think was
her first major role yeah
you know everybody in the movie is
attractive in some way you know they're
like uh larger than life personalities i
was thinking in particular when i was
thinking about the ad-libs
you know the scene near the beginning
where uh where
frederick or frederick as igor calls
them yeah but um when he's
saying goodbye to madeleine khan at the
train station
and she's like he's trying to like hug
her and kiss her and she's just like oh
my hair and oh this is
happening this and that the other yeah
and uh one of the best things is he
finally gets on the train and he blows
her a kiss
and she moves like out of the way and
that was ad-libbed also what's his name
again
uh what what's what's guy played igor
what's it what's your party fellaini
yeah this guy man
i mean that dude is so strange looking
his eyes
and his and just the way he's standing
and everything he's doing he's just
playing up kind of like the oddity that
is this guy
but he's kind of mesmerizing in a way
yeah yeah i mean i mean that role
obviously was written uh
specifically for him i don't know how
he's getting his eyes to bug out because
sometimes
no they just they look like that they
look like that um he had a thyroid
condition
that um that kind of like it was like
inflammatory and it like affected his
eyes
sometimes sometimes his eyelids are
opened almost like an eighth of an inch
above and below the damn irish that's
why yeah
but sometimes it's not as much depends
on what what his expressions were
it almost looked like he had some kind
of special skill that he could open his
eyes that far
no they always look like that's always
like that yeah it's called what's it
called graves ophthalmology something or
other things
cross-eyed and it's just yeah it's
bizarre bad real [ __ ] bizarre but he
plays right into he leans into this
character
no one else could nobody else could have
done this that role nobody else could
have done that
no definitely not i was uh yeah i was
like reading his wikipedia page sadly uh
he died pretty young but
um yeah he had like a thyroid condition
like from earlier
and he was saying something like and he
was actually in a bunch of stuff like
british tv and uh things like that you
know
comedy he was a comedian and uh before
he even did young frankenstein so he was
pretty well established
and he they asked him about you know
he's like i don't know if i would have
got so much work if i didn't look
so weird because he's like yeah i could
probably have surgery and have all this
fixed but it's like then i'd just be
like a random ass actor that looked like
everybody else
so he attributed his career to like how
how weird he looked
the guys from hills have eyes yeah right
it's like you might as well just make it
work for you you know what i mean but
like i said he died um
in his 40s like he had a heart attack um
on the set of yellow beard do you
remember that like that pirate movie
that came out in 83 yeah and that was
his last movie like he died while he was
in the hotel like uh
at the but they said well he uh mel
brooks said it might have been because
uh he smoked about two cartons of
cigarettes a week and like
uh drank endless amounts of coffee and
he was just like what was funny is that
you could tell during one of the scenes
that he was doing some um
he did like a little bit of light
acrobatics when he was coming down the
stairs
yeah and he was he's wearing a pretty
cool outfit it was like a cloak
that went over and underneath that cloak
sometimes you throw his arms back it was
kind of like a
a black real tight fitting unitard
it was like a unitard with like shorts
over it and
little goth pixie boot looking things
and it looked like something out of an
old
1930s horror movie but you could tell he
was
real physically fit in terms of like he
was extremely lean
he had to believe that he was drinking
that much
without gaining a whole bunch of well he
had thyroid problems so i'd imagine that
would probably keep you pretty [ __ ]
slow
it was coffee he was talking they said
they said that he was like a coffee
addict
also he smoked a lot yeah that's what
mel brooks said he was real
slim i would say 130 540 pounds yeah he
was he was a little dude
yeah but uh yeah i mean the whole gag
about like the hump
changing sides and then like him not
even uh
being aware of the hump you know what i
mean it's like you know i could fix that
that for you and he's like fix what he's
like the hump what hump
and then like there would be a scene i
think you missed it cause i think you
were in the bathroom but it's like it
was on the other side
and then gene wilder's like wasn't that
on the and then like he's looking at him
like
i like he didn't know what he was
talking about yeah but it's just kind of
like i mean
this [ __ ] movie i feel like this
movie has so
saturated the public consciousness like
i said i was reading an article that
came out a few years ago
uh about it on av club and it seemed
like
there was like three or four hundred
comments and almost all of them were
like
quoting from the [ __ ] movie just
because everybody
i mean everybody loves this [ __ ]
movie it's just like has so many great
iconic
[ __ ] scenes it's just the whole thing
with frau blooker and like the [ __ ]
horse winning every time they say her
name yeah and she's exasperated
you can't say her name without the damn
horses going crazy and it's like i've
even watched a couple of uh reviews of
this by like younger guys and every time
they say probably occur in there they
have like a horse-winning side effect
which i thought about doing but then i
was like well probably everyone will do
that so i'm not gonna do it
one okay so like i said everybody in
this is
awesome um i particularly love there's a
couple scenes in this i really really
love
i really love the scene early on in the
movie
where gene wilder is giving the lecture
like to the medical students right and
he plays so much of that just completely
straight
and he's just in there and he's just
like drawing the brain thing because
he's a neurosurgeon or whatever and he's
like drawing the brain thing on the
board and then he has that uh well
actually [ __ ] that like stands
up
in the [ __ ] front row and it's like
you know he
keeps calling him frank frankenstein if
he's like my name
is frankenstein sean had distanced
himself from his grandfather who made
the frankenstein monster
it it's pretty cool man i liked it and
then him like stabbing himself in the
leg with the [ __ ] scalpel and then
trying to like
lay it off it's just kind of like like
having a freak out over it
tonally visually i mean
um the humor is different but kind of
similar that
if you liked ed wood you would like this
movie
it's a little more over the top than it
ed would because you know
it's not about an actual person of
course you know but it
it just reminded me of that movie in
certain ways not just because it was
just black
and white just the visual and the
spiritual tone behind it
it's just a good movie well you can tell
that tim burton was really influenced by
this
movie in particular like when he made
edward okay another thing about this too
was that mel brooks
he specifically wanted this to look like
like i said a universal movie from the
1930s
so he did the same thing with like all
the different kind of wipes and stuff
like that that they used to do he used
the same cinematography
and he insisted he's like this is going
to be shot in black and white
now the first uh studio because i think
he went to columbia first
and they were like no no no you have to
shoot it in color and he's like yeah no
i don't want to do that
and they were trying to like trick him
because they were like oh well
you can shoot it and well you shoot it
in color and then we'll show it in black
and white he's like [ __ ] i'm not
doing that because you're just gonna
like show it in [ __ ] color so he
finally went to 20th century fox and
they said fine
you can do it in black and white so he
did and so like i said the
cinematography the way the
you know the scene transitions the way
it's shot is pretty much exactly like
a movie from that era and i think that's
really cool that they stuck to their
guns
and said we want it to look exactly like
that and the scene too like in the
lab when they bring the monster to life
all almost all of the equipment in the
background
that was all the equipment from the
original frankenstein movies
which somebody they heard that somebody
had it like just stored it
he was like yeah it's just in my garage
or something like that and bell brooks
goes to the dude's house he's like can
we rent this
yeah and the dude was like sure yeah
so he the guy came and like set it all
up i can't remember his name but
he came and set it all up for them and
showed him like how it worked and [ __ ]
like that and i'm like that's pretty
[ __ ] awesome
also the whole thing too with um i was
gonna say uh gene hackman
oh yeah being the blind man which like i
said that was a parody of a scene from
uh bride of frankenstein
and um gene hackman was actually i don't
think he was actually even supposed to
be in the movie
um but he was working on a movie or he
was like playing tennis with gene wilder
like they were friends or something
and he was kind of like um hey gene what
have you guys been working on he's like
oh we're doing this frankenstein parody
and stuff like that and gene's like um
can i be in it yeah and jean's like um
sure if you want well because at this
point you have to think like gene uh
gene hackman
had written had uh you know been in a
bunch of movies he had like won some
oscars at this point but i don't think
he'd done any comedy
prior to this but he so he wanted to
kind of like expand so he wanted to do
something funny
uh so they said well yeah we can do this
like parody of this blind man scene and
you can be the blind man and he [ __ ]
killed it yeah
he killed it and i mean even that [ __ ]
about the end like where he was saying
where the monster like took off and he
was like no wait come back and there's
like a big long pause he's like i was
just gonna make espresso that was also
an ad-lib
another thing about the movie is that
it's strangely it's it's strangely not
only is it funny it's uh
it's sexual it's got a [ __ ] good
sexual a sense of sexual humor
like frankenstein's a size monster
there's a certain kind of women that
like the size that like the size that
they get that gets into there what else
gets into there well
yeah difference between size and brains
and then how sometimes that [ __ ] could
work out
um there's a lot of themes in there
[ __ ] funny
um the idea that uh
you may not be you may not actually be
banging your fiance you might be banging
the the uh
you might be banging the secretary
basically but then that works out
well yeah because madeline yeah better
yeah all right you know
so there's all kinds of [ __ ] funny
[ __ ] in there you know what i mean
it probably wouldn't fly today but it
[ __ ] to me it aged
well the thing well no because it's
pretty mild sexual humor it's pretty
much all just innuendo
yeah um so i feel like even like a
little kid watching they probably
wouldn't know what they were talking
about i saw it as a little kid i didn't
remember that
yeah didn't get it because i feel like
blazing saddles was kind of
more um they had like a lot of racial
jokes they had a lot of fart jokes stuff
like that this wouldn't fly
this one was kind of more sexual humor
but in a in sort of like a cute it was
tasteful
way yeah it's like it's not like did you
want to have a roll in the hay
that was yeah funny [ __ ] man well the
the thing about it is that
it was mel brooks's idea he's like you
know we want to have like some kind of
you know innuendo and like sexual stuff
in the movie
but he's like it would be funnier if we
gave all the lines to terry garr
who was just kind of like this innocent
sort of character
and it's like so every time she says
something sexual she doesn't realize
that it's sexual yeah yeah
you know what i mean it's like so it's
makes it like way funnier yeah it just
shows jean's face and he's trying to
like going he's going uh
yeah what knocker is there anything i
can do for you
anything i can do for you and he's like
yeah
she's rubbing on his fingers and [ __ ] if
there's anything like that he's like you
release your attention and yeah
that's [ __ ] funny [ __ ] i'm just like
everyone can see that this is like a
[ __ ] classic scene
i just feel like there's so many that
it's like you could just sit here all
day and just like recite all the good
[ __ ]
and i had forgotten you know what i had
forgotten too that parody of the scene
where the monster gets out
and then meets the little girl you know
what it's like but it's for parodying
the first scene where you know in the
first frankenstein where frankenstein
accidentally
surrounds her drowns that girl and like
throws her in the river because he
thinks she's gonna float
and so i love that they kind of parodied
that where it's like the little girl's
throwing flowers down a well
like good all the flowers go oh the
flower is all gone now what should we
throw down there and then the monster
kind of
looks look at the candle
that's not what happened but that's that
was she actually saved the girl they
don't kill the girl in there
because they had had they killed the
girl they wouldn't have been able to do
the big unveiling in the
in the dance routine yeah because he'd
have been a wanted man
yeah so they couldn't have been a happy
ending because this one uh
unlike the normal frankenstein moves
have a it has a happy ending
yeah yeah frankenstein hooks up
[Laughter]
well yeah they do like a brain trans
well but because i mean gene wilder like
because he
he much it's unlike the original story
because the whole point of the original
novel was that
dr frankenstein made this thing and then
refused to take responsibility for it
which is what caused all of these
you know bad things to happen so it was
kind of like you know about hubris or
whatever
but this one is kind of more like uh
makes
dr frankenstein he's not actually the
actual dr frankenstein he's like his
great grandson or whatever
and um his grandson is great grandson i
can't remember
and um his uh grandson yeah because it
was his grandfather
well yeah because it was his
great-grandfather baron that had the box
that they brought the box
but then he said it was his grandfather
it was victor yeah yeah
but um yeah so so the fact that
he is a better person and he creates the
monster but then he takes responsibility
for the monster
and he's like i'll give him part of my
brain so he can be a normal person
instead of like a lumbering
yeah creature um you know and he gets
you know he gets something in return he
gets something in return yeah
what did you get out of that he's just
looking at the camera
you hear her [ __ ] going doing the
yodeling and
you know exactly what what he got out of
that at least he got some of that
and i just i gotta say too i love love
love that last scene
with madeleine khan and the monster like
the monster's got on his jammies
and his glasses and he's in the bed
reading the wall street journal
and she comes out of the bathroom with
the [ __ ] bride of frankenstein hair
that's like the [ __ ] yeah she's in
her teddy and [ __ ]
she's in her teddy and then she does
that she's
trying to entice him he's looking at the
camera for the smirk and [ __ ]
i mean she said i mean i love madeline
khan it's like she wasn't in this a lot
she was only like in the beginning of
like a little bit at the end
um but she's just so [ __ ] great in
this and it's just
i mean oh my god so feel somebody great
yeah
even even frau what's her name [ __ ]
who was probably blocker yeah even from
look
[ __ ] she was strangely hot in this he
[ __ ]
but she they have her made up to look a
little older than she really is she's
probably only about 40
i would think in real life but they kind
of made her try to make her look like
she was 60 or something
yeah well because i feel like she was
still when they did because i think
fairly recently i don't remember what
year it was but fairly recently they did
a musical version of this like a live
like a theater musical
and clara sleechman was still alive then
because they asked her to reprise her
role as flower book
frow [ __ ] real she ended up not
being able to do it real skinny kind of
ghostly gaunt
spooky kind of like a female version of
of uh
peter cushing that's what she kind of
looked like that's kind of what they had
her made up and she was
ghostly looking every time she said her
name the [ __ ] horse was a good
creature
and then she'd be like that's still
funny every single time
and then i love they had that one like
it kept doing it and everybody's like
what the [ __ ] and then like
there's like a pause and then marty
feldman pops out and he's like look her
so
it's like the [ __ ] dude but uh yeah
so the thing with uh another thing that
was an ad lib
was when uh gene wilder first gets to
the castle
and frau blocker is up there like trying
to ask him if he wanted anything like if
he wanted some brandy or something
before he goes to bed and he's just like
no i'm really tired
then she starts walking away and she's
like warm milk
he's like no no thank you come on to him
oval team
no no no that was she asking for a
brandy would you yeah
randy and she's definitely coming on to
him he's like uh no
yeah then warm milk
[Laughter]
no that would be just trying to talk her
way up into his jeans
it didn't work because she was screwing
around with his grandfather or yeah
grandfather yeah and they looked exactly
alike
he looked cool but uh wilder looked
really cool in this flick he kind of had
a hair dude like you'd maybe see out of
sweeney todd or something
and it was but it was blonde and um
he just they kind of had him in old
1930s style stage makeup you know with
the eyeliner and stuff
yeah you're doing an old horror movie he
just looked cool
running around and damn doctor's outfits
and
you know top hat and tails and just like
out of an old
universal film you know and uh nah
yeah this i think this is maybe one of
his strongest movies i mean it
it's hard to kind of beat this
performance of willy wonka from what i'm
you know from what i remember i got to
see blazing i got to see blazing saddles
and i got to see stir crazy again i'll
eventually
come up with the best wilder movie but
this one's got to be up there
i mean i think i like his performance in
this one the same reason that i like his
performance in willy wonka is because
like you said he seems like he's
teetering just on the edge of sanity but
like even when he's being like straight
or normal
it's still got that tension to it and
that still like makes it really funny
i mean like one of the one of the best
scenes in this
is when you know you know after like uh
igor goes and like steals the abnormal
brain
the abnormal brain do not use this brain
it says oh and also when he's breaking
into the thing i don't think i ever
noticed this before
but on the front of the door it says
something like after 5 pm slide brain
through slotted or whatever it was like
the brain depository
another thing that he does is he never
breaks character but you can tell he and
he's doing it on purpose he's
telegraphing to you that
he's on the edge of [ __ ] laughing
because this [ __ ] is ridiculous
you could tell that yes just underneath
there that he's pulling a joke on you
the audience and he knows and you know
and he knows that you know that he does
so it's kind of like he's
it's just you'll see what i'm talking
about if you've never seen the movie
there's actually definitely [ __ ] with
you there's actually one scene
where well because they said that they
had to do so many takes over again
because he kept cracking up and everyone
else would crack up and so they have to
do it over
yeah but there was the one scene where
um where madeleine khan first gets to
the castle
and um igor is like kind of like chewing
on her uh
her first hole there or whatever i think
that gene wilder kind of lost it in the
back and they just like left it again
yeah but uh yeah but i mean one of my
favorite things
yeah yeah well because like i said they
said he just kept like
cracking up because as i said they were
you know they were uh you know
ad-libbing a lot of stuff a very analog
movie yeah you know i mean it's it's not
it's it's not contrived per se it's like
it's like you're watching a really good
live performance
they're definitely [ __ ] with you yeah
they're [ __ ] with you through the
camera so there's almost kind of like an
interaction you feel like you're
watching a live performance
but it's that's the thing it's like it's
a parody but it's an affectionate parody
yeah yeah
and like i said they did a deep dive i
mean it would have been very easy
to just do a parody of frankenstein but
the fact that they actually
you know recreated scenes from first
frankenstein bride of frankenstein son
of frankenstein
to the extent that they even put that
inspector character in there with the
wooden arm
and like i said if you see son of
frankenstein like from whatever like the
30s or whenever it came out
you you think that that's a joke in the
movie that he has the wooden arm and he
sticks the darts in it but he does that
in the original movie too
oh man they just they just like um you
know they they exaggerated a little bit
like the way he talks and everything
yeah um i mean the [ __ ] about him saying
it's like a riot is an ugly thing and i
think it's about time we had one or
something like that
[ __ ] funny and then like all the [ __ ]
that he said
like everybody's like what because
nobody can understand his accent yeah
there's more snapchat for snapped he
made sense to me though
yeah you can yeah you can understand it
well i meant on a spiritual level yeah
and so we got to do it
yeah made the perfect sense yeah sounds
good
but yeah i mean what i was going to say
what i was starting to say a long time
ago was that the scene where
he uh you know when uh you know igor has
stolen the abnormal brain because he
dropped uh the one that they that he was
supposed to get
and they put it in there and then uh i
love
gene wilder is just like so so calm and
he's just like
come here i would you know i want to
talk to you a second just like sit down
you know what i mean and
igor sits down and he's like and he's
like uh
whose brain did you you know this is not
the brain that i was
like no and he's like okay good good
good and then he's like saying something
like well whose brain
is it abby someone yeah abby someone
yeah abby who yeah
well you won't be mad i will not be mad
you know what i mean and it's just that
whole [ __ ] scene is great because
he's just like so
calm but then he just [ __ ] loses it
like toward the end i mean that one and
the one where he gets grabbed by the
monster and then he's trying to
he's trying to do like [ __ ] uh what
do you call it what do you call that
game where you
[ __ ] you should try to get people to
say the word okay
charades yeah yeah when he's trying to
do charades like to get him to give him
the
yeah sedative and they're being all
stupid obvious what he needs
is that again
like he's just so indignant it's like so
[ __ ] funny
but it's just i mean like i said if you
like old universal horror movies if you
like comedies
that are funny um then i can't believe
that there's anyone on this earth that
has not seen this movie
sure there's a lot of young people that
have never seen this movie but
it's not a movie of today this is a
movie of another era but it's aged very
well it's kind of a timeless classic
you know it's just you just watch it
watch it and enjoy
and it takes you on a little journey and
they just it's a [ __ ]
expert cast of comedians
that are putting on a story and they're
just [ __ ] with you
through the camera they're just [ __ ]
with you through the whole thing
but you're having a good time they're
telling it to you in the they're telling
you this story in the format of a 1930s
universal horror movie i mean it's just
so great like i said it's just such an
affectionate homage and the nice thing
about it is that you can watch it
just on its own um you know what i mean
and it's just like funny and it's like a
good story on its own too
but if you why if you've seen the
original three
first free frank first three
frankenstein universal movies
it'll be much much funnier because
you'll be able to see exactly like
what they were parodying and how close
they got to actually making a movie that
could have been made
back then i mean their commitment to
that was just really really admirable
see i'd only seen frankenstein i've
never seen son of frankenstein so i
didn't get the
inspector here yeah the chief of police
guy
i love that dark there was normally a
chief of the police in in
these horror movies and they were all
kind of like that so yeah just i just
accepted it for what it was i didn't
know it was a direct parody
of a character yeah but it makes more
sense that you too i mean he had the eye
patch with a monocle over the ipad
where are they supposed to be romania
it's well they said transylvanian and
they were in melbourne
german i know yeah well see that's the
thing mel brooks and
uh gene wilder they're like look we know
that frankenstein wasn't set
in uh transformation yeah but he's like
we decided to do that because
we just figured oh it's funnier because
like everybody knows where transylvania
is it's like
we can't do like engelstad or anything
like that because people be like where
the [ __ ] is that
oh but yeah i mean i love that i love
that whole sequence where he's playing
darts with the inspector
and like you know he keeps like the
inspector's like cheating like he just
takes them all and he just like sneaks
over there and sticks a ball in the
middle
and then like he's like you know gene
wilder's throwing the [ __ ] darts at
the thing and he keeps like [ __ ] with
him and he's like
saying a word loud while he's throwing
it so it goes like out the window and
[ __ ] like that
and then they like set it up later it's
like you see that and then like a few
minutes later when the inspector leaves
in the car like all the tires are flat
because they all have darts in them he's
got an eye patch
and the monocle is over the eye patch
yeah it took me away
it took me a minute to [ __ ] to
realize what they were doing that's what
i mean like some of the best gags in it
are just not
referred to and i think that's like
something that really makes comedies
like this work and
why they're so rewatchable because
they're such like a layered experience
because a lot of the gags aren't
telegraphed or they aren't
you know they don't like draw attention
to them like hey funny you know what i
mean it's just they're just there and if
you notice them
then cool and if you don't yeah they say
that they're in transylvania but they're
obviously in germany
yeah you know trent that transylvania
that's [ __ ]
romania that's vampires i know dracula
like i said they know
or maybe austria you know yeah it was
kind of cool though it's just funny
well yeah that but like i said they were
aware they were just kind of like we
just called it transylvania because
everybody knows where that is
uh knows that name or knows that name
it's like like i said we can't
because because i think like i said i
think most of uh frankenstein was set in
uh
ingolstadt wasn't it i think this is
where it was that's where the university
oh [ __ ] no no i can't remember now i
thought the board has changed a lot
that's what i'm saying so i can't
remember exactly like when the novel
came out which was what 18
16 18 18 something like that yeah the
borders i'm not sure even germany
existed as an independent state
in the 1800s because i know a lot of
stuff was
austria and then there was some other
stuff with like an austro-hungarian
empire
yeah you know i i i don't think the
actual country of germany as you know it
today isn't very old i don't think i
think it's 1800s
yeah yeah but uh but yeah so like i said
you know if you haven't seen the movie
probably watch the universal ones first
and then watch this one because it'll be
much funnier but i mean that said you
don't have to have seen them
it helps though like you know what i'm
saying it makes it funnier i think
but it's still funny even without that
honestly i think
this is easily my favorite mel brooks
movie i mean easily i thought like i
said
maybe blazing saddles is slightly
funnier but
i don't know that's kind of like a hard
you at least wants to make
you at least want to see the original
frankenstein before you see this movie
though
yeah and if you said son of frankenstein
yeah i want to see that too they're not
very long those old movies
yeah well and bride of frankenstein i
think is like the best one of
out of all those three so getting on
bride of frank you know it was no it was
[ __ ] up about bride of frankenstein
what's that
the bride wasn't in it for very long she
didn't do very much she only appeared at
the end and she was hot as [ __ ]
especially for the time they're gonna do
you know what i mean
you gotta tell us the more a story and
it ends yeah it doesn't last for very
long
it should have been a whole movie at her
yeah that's true
yeah and the thing about it well i mean
bride of frankenstein that actually
that bit was in the original novel but
it just wasn't in the original movie you
know what i mean because they
in the novel he does end up making the
monster a mate
like later on so it's not like they just
pulled that out of their body what's
actually in the book
he makes the bride so so the original
frankenstein could have a
girlfriend and as soon as she comes to
life what does she do she goes after the
high guys she's not going to go after
the [ __ ] frankie i'm pretty sure
that's i mean in the internet
in the book she's not in it much either
because it's just kind of like
um you know he makes the mate and then
she's just kind of like hey i don't like
this monster [ __ ] that [ __ ] yeah they
end up having a destroyer yeah
right which you know what are you gonna
do right that's
what happened yeah it's like [ __ ]
shouldn't have given her a reminder of
her own
should have made her ugly so she didn't
have a choice
yeah it's like why did you miss you it's
like she's good-looking the monster is
like funny-looking
you know what i mean yeah made equals
yeah you would think yeah but you know
that's you can't have ugly ladies in
movies it's not allowed
well it was true to life though yeah
okay if a guy's going to make a a
a woman and bring her to life she's
going to be hot yeah that's what he's
going to spend his money on
his time his money would be money too
well yeah
okay and then you know like a typical
guy he's not has he's not thinking it
through
a typical guy as [ __ ] duh
oh i forgot yeah she's not gonna want to
date this dude yeah
yeah i mean you know what you should see
you should probably see
uh the movie the bride with sting and
jennifer beals
in it and clancy brown yeah because that
is pretty much tells the story of the
bride of frankenstein but the bride
is much more like she's actually a
character right
and pretty much what happens is that
sting as dr frankenstein
he makes the the lady and like you said
makes her hot and it's just like oh i'm
keeping this one
okay and then the monster gets pissed
off and like takes off
and uh but you know stinks that's
another thing that would happen yeah
well sting's kind of a chode tour though
so she doesn't really like him like
like he actually falls in love with her
and he like teaches her all this stuff
but he's real like possessive and shitty
yeah
and uh she's kind of like yeah no i'm
i'm not and she ends up with the monster
anyway
because he's nicer to her eventually
these dweebs are gonna start making
robots that are like that and then
they're not going to get married
this could be the end of the species
just dudes making these damn robots and
selling them to other dudes
and women having to buy robot boyfriends
no children then you have to have
in vitro fertilization and you got two
parallel species
the biological one and a technological
one imagine that
i'll be i'll be long dead before that
happens this hopes up
i don't really care about it i'm hoping
that it doesn't really advance that far
no i don't think it will yeah i think
maybe civilization goes through cycles
and eventually
well the thing about it is that i could
do that even if they did have the
technology for that it would probably
only be like a pretty
small a relatively small percentage of
people that would actually
do that do that would probably be quite
embarrassing
yeah you know it probably would be like
having a sex doll
yeah that's how they would like a real
girl or whatever the [ __ ] those things
are called
like those creepy realistic ones there
was a there was a movie called
bicentennial man had robin williams yeah
i remember that and they made all these
robots and they got very sophisticated
but then eventually in the story and he
lived like 200 years
eventually what happened is people
stopped making them because they didn't
like them
yeah and they kind of went out of style
i kind of feel like that's probably what
would happen probably what would happen
i'd you know
just saying let's hope because that
would be a direct competitor if they got
real good
yeah yeah but you know i don't know i'm
not worried about it
but yeah you youngsters out there if you
haven't seen young frankenstein
you should watch it it's on hulu yeah um
and
even if you're old or you haven't seen
it for a long time go watch it again it
really really does hold up
i mean it's still really funny like i
said between that and blazing saddles
easily his best
i'm like you know what i should probably
watch baseballs again i remember loving
that movie when i was a kid i remember
not liking it but i don't know if it's
still
funny or not i remember a lot of the
gags from it but
i really liked uh history of the world
and watched it fairly recently and it
didn't age well
yeah i thought the humor [ __ ] was
real lame
yeah it's that's the thing some other
thing and i and i heard that the
original cut of young frankenstein was
like
they filmed like five hours worth of
[ __ ] movie oh yeah and then finally
they were just like there were so many
like jokes and stuff and some of them
didn't work as well so it's like they
finally ended up cutting it down to
whatever it is now which is like an hour
and 40 something minutes
but uh yeah apparently they apparently
was way way longer but they thought that
some of the jokes didn't work so they
took them all out
but you know but yeah so it's on hulu
go watch it right now it's super fun
and i love it so you know we'll see you
on the next one
bye